madame monsieur bonsoir les malheurs les
gens les retrouve bien assez tôt le rire
on en aura toujours besoin
c'est ce qu'avait à dire louis de funès
l'acteur comique le plus apprécié des
français
l'homme dans les grimaces les
ricanements et le rire fit rire et
feront rire encore des millions et des
millions de gens louis de funès est mort
la nuit dernière à nantes des suites
d'un accident cardiaque il avait 68 ans
il avait été victime d'un premier
accident cardiaque en 1975 et depuis il
vivait le plus possible dans son château
de clermont près de nantes où il aimait
taille et les roses louis de funès qui
s'éteint donc en pleine gloire son
dernier film le gendarme et les
gendarmettes date de quelques mois
louis de funès avait tourné plus de 100
films avant de devenir vers 40 ans une
immense vedette populaire la carrière sa
carrière émaillée de quelques morceaux
de choix george v go ah les belles
bacchantes et les spectacles
branquignols de robert dhéry ont été les
premiers pas vers la gloire
puis au théâtre il y eut le grand succès
d'oscar qui deviendra un film de bodinat
au je le dirai vous avez cherché ses
bijoux et pourrait gonfler comme cadeau
de fiançailles
alors de cette façon sa mère ne pourra
plus rien vous croyez en 1964 jean
giraud qu'il avait déjà employée dans
wii puis va offrir à de funès le premier
film de la série des gendarmes c'est
l'explosion de sa popularité
on l'utilisé aujourd'hui
et voilà c'est reparti il a suffi que je
sois là
à
quelquefois on disait m'aidait pas
commode non autonomes qui était très
très timide des heureux s'ils ne vous
connaissez pas bien ils avaient ils
avaient ils avaient une peur ils avaient
peu il avait une panique mettez qui vous
connaissez bien dès que vous deveniez un
ami alors c'était un enchantement parce
que chaque minute cet homme
voyez quelque chose de drôle que vous
n'aviez pas perçu et il voulait vous
transmettiez alors rush bon pleurer de
rire avec lui je connaissais comme homme
et c'est un homme qui lorsqu'il était à
l'aise qu'ils étaient vraiment très
charmant simple avec moi avec les gens
aimant la vie du pays
il était un de vos fidèles à leurs
produits paroissiens c'est un précieux
comme les autres est très fidèle lui
c'est un chrétien ou pratiquer
régulièrement et à une fois très
profonde
gérard oury à l'idée d'associer de funès
à bourvil en 1965 le succès du corniaud
est prodigieux il y a là un couple de
comédiens dont le jeu se complètent
admirablement bien
cependant la red bull c'est pas grave
qu'est ce que je vais devenir moi un
piéton peut plus vrai mais même mes
vacances au futur appartient pour
l'italie le projet d'intérêt public mais
c'est mon vrai comique devient comique
de situation saleh s'est elle acquit la
situation c'est toujours les la plus
grande situation du monde c'est un
monsieur qui lit son journal avec une
chaise quelqu'un s'approche dans l ue
une bombe là dessous est il temps de les
pages il n'y a pas deux et je voudrais
arriver à faire un film comique à biot
un film un film muet muet mais c'est
très difficile à effet mais pas muet
comme du temps du muet lui et avec tous
les bruits les sons mais où les gens
s'ils n'ont pas parlé qui y mangent pas
très bonne est vous qui parler vous avez
un beau trop en dessous pris en 1967 la
grande vadrouille battra tous les
records de recettes c'est sans doute
pour de funès le sommet d'une carrière
qui compte une centaine de films de
valeurs très inégale
mende ou bavarder toujours ça soyez avec
nous j'avais la langue bien pendue bon
sens en prenant numéro 17 qui a fait ça
c'est moi veut et où vous croyez vous à
l'opéra veut très amusant chanter mes
fistons marguerite force toute sorte et
je ne veux personne dans la salle
lorsque je travaille je ne veux que
perdu en dix mois
voilà est bon